LARS RYSSDAL: All right.
Thank you.
Good morning, still.
Everyone, hope you're hungry.
Great to be here today.
We're absolutely thrilled.
This is our first time with
"Art Culinaire" magazine coming
to the Zagat Kitchen
here at Google.
And we-- myself
and Carol Newman,
who's sitting right over
here-- publish a magazine that
has been in existence for
28, going on 29 years.
The magazine is called
"Art Culinaire."
It's a hardbound
magazine quarterly
that has been showcasing the
great chefs in the world.
We-- Carol had been the
editor of the magazine
for several years
in its former life.
And we were able to bring
the magazine to California
in May of last year.
And Carol has the
pleasure and honor
of curating the chefs
for the magazine.
And in looking at who to talk
about and who to discover
and who's really
interesting and provides
great reading and
beautiful food,
it was not difficult in
the early stages of our
developing the material
for the magazine
that we centered on a
young man in Oakland who
is a fascinating fellow,
handsome as all get out,
benevolent and talented.
I think I said that already.
But you can't say it enough.
So today, we have James.
And we'll have him
re-pronounce his last name.
It's Syhabout.
From Commis.
He has several restaurants.
We'll talk about the different
sort of iterations of his mind
and personality as it translates
into the restaurants he owns.
The dish that he's doing
today-- we'll talk about--
is a cured salmon dish that
appears in "Art Culinaire 113."
I don't know if I
mentioned the magazine yet.
We'll have these
available for James
to sign for you at the end.
The dish that we'll
be doing today,
again, the cured salmon dish--
I've got it bookmarked here--
will look exactly like this.
OK?
And then after James
tells you how to make it,
you guys can run home and
make it yourself and send us
pictures to make sure
that it looks exactly
like this when you're
cooking it in your homes.
OK?
So I come from a family
that moved to America.
I was born after my
family moved from Norway.
And my sisters and I--
our dear departed mother
had an extremely strong accent.
And your organization
built a server plant
on the footprint of the aluminum
plant my father used to manage.
And when they came to this
small town on the Columbia River
in Oregon, my mom
was very excited.
And she has this
affected accent.
And if I say "Gyoogle,"
actually, I can't help it.
It's my mother's
Norwegian accent.
And she leaned on the Os
like a big long search.
So if I'm "Gyoogling," I'm
thinking about my mother.
The reason why I say that is
because James has-- his mother
is an incredibly important
part of his life.
And we're going to
hand it over to James
to talk about that primarily.
The role of your mom in
your adult life in business
in Oakland-- how does
that work for you?
JAMES SYHABOUT: I'm
a restaurant kid.
So I grew up in restaurants
before I was a teenager.
I knew I wanted to cook since
I was 10 professionally.
I was the kid who was
sitting on the stools
in the mom-and-pop
Thai restaurants,
picking stems off Thai
chilies, peeling garlic.
I didn't have a normal
weekend, because my weekend
was helping the family business.
But I enjoyed what I was doing.
I have no regrets at all.
And then it took a
turn with TV and seeing
the great chefs of Europe.
And it was so much
different than what
I've experienced in my
parents' restaurant.
Who are these guys in these nice
white starched jackets, cooking
this beautiful food?
And it was totally the opposite
of what my parents were doing.
They were just-- Thai food.
So it sparked my
curiosity, and I
decided to pursue
it as a career.
I went to culinary school.
It definitely wasn't a
highlight in my career,
but I just started training.
You know?
Manresa down in Los Gatos was
somewhat my breeding ground.
I've been there for five
years, and it kind of
sparked me to get
more interested.
So I took a trip to
Europe for a year.
It was like grad school for me.
I ate out as much
as I can, burning
holes in all my credit cards.
And it was worth
every penny of it.
But going back full circle,
why I got involved in cooking
and why I like
cooking is-- is anyone
familiar with my
restaurants at all?
They're all very different,
if you notice-- Commis
to Hawker Fare to The Dock.
I've always been told,
if you ever do something,
and you're really into it,
have it reflect who you are.
Commis really
represents by training.
It's kind of my discipline.
So the OCD part of me is Commis.
It's my training.
But the soulfulness of
who I am, my identity,
is Hawker Fare, kind of
cooking Thai street food,
kind of rediscovering myself.
And they say, as you
get older, you kind of
gravitate towards your past
and try to identity search.
So that's a big part of it for
me right now is Hawker Fare.
I'm opening one.
After I leave here, we're
opening-- opening night
at Hawker Fare, San
Francisco is tonight.
So we have a big
night ahead of us.
I did The Dock.
The Dock is West Oakland.
That's where I grew up.
Oakland public
schools all the way.
It's just kind of a
sense of community
that people-- Oakland
gets a bad rap in general.
But there's a beauty
I see in West Oakland
that no one else sees.
My partner Adam Lamoreaux
opened the first brewery there
in 50 years.
Me and him partnered up and put
a restaurant next door to it.
And looking around The Dock,
conceptually, what is The Dock?
We're in the melting pot of
the Bay Area, all the shipping
containers.
And we decided, let's make
it an international place.
There's no rules.
West Oakland, there's
no rules in general.
There's not-- a
neighborhood doesn't exist.
So who do we cater to?
It was like, let's just do what
we want and take it from there.
As long as the food's
delicious, the vibe is great,
building a sense of community.
And we kind of took
it and ran with it.
It kind of simplifies
my street hood years.
We play lots of hip-hop.
We have-- we're going to
start doing shows there,
like Hieroglyphics day,
the Oakland hip-hop band.
So yeah.
So it comes around full circle.
So it's many compartments
of myself, per se.
But "Art Culinaire,"
one of the magazines
I worshipped as a kid-- I think
I have issues from number 50
until now.
It's a quarterly magazine,
idolizing all these chefs.
And I was given a great
opportunity to take part.
And how could I say no?
All the chefs I idolized
in the past, you name them,
they're in there.
So it was a real blessing
to be a part of it.
In the book, we're
going to do more
of what I do at Commis,
which is a reflection
of a place and a time.
It's a snapshot.
The dish in the book--
it was a spring dish.
So it was green tomatoes, wild
salmon, wild coastal herbs
that we foraged for
or my cooks foraged
for in the coast, up in
the hills of Oakland.
So it's like a landscape on
the plate, an edible landscape.
But today, we're going
to kind of switch gears.
We're doing the same
dish, but I want
to let you know it's more
about the ideology of the dish
and the philosophy and the
thought, the train of thought,
more so than the dish itself.
Techniques can be
utilized universally,
just swap out ingredients.
That's all we're doing.
That's all we're doing
as chefs, and kind
of adjusting to what your
ingredient is, per se.
So today, we're going
to do-- we're still
in the middle of
winter, so kohlrabi.
It is a swollen cabbage
stem in the brassica family,
so same family as kale,
cauliflower, spinach, broccoli,
romanesco.
So we're going to
do a soup with this
with dill instead
of green tomatoes.
LARS RYSSDAL: And we've
got dill and some--
JAMES SYHABOUT: It's
a very simple dish.
The more and more--
as I get older,
I'm realizing the most simple
cooking is the hardest to do.
I always think about sushi.
It's just fish and rice.
But it's absolutely the
hardest thing to get right.
I find myself, sometimes
I pile on ingredients.
It's like, maybe
it's because I'm
trying to hide something and not
let it be bare and kind of let
it speak for itself.
Soup is really simple.
Take some kohlrabi.
Actually-- yeah, we'll
do the soup first
because we'll take-- kohlrabi,
I like to use the whole plant,
if you will.
There's also purple kohlrabi.
It's just the skins.
That's the coloring difference.
The inside flesh is the same.
So there's parts of
the kohlrabi that you
want to trim pretty deep, only
because it's very fibrous.
And being at Commis, we
want to make everything
very elegant and
very silky smooth.
So all these fibers will
kind of get in our way
when you're trying
to achieve that.
You can also use a mandolin.
I use mandolins all the time.
Just watch your fingers.
But even though we're
cooking it in the soup,
I still like to
slice it very thin.
It creates less work
for the blender.
LARS RYSSDAL: So the
mandolin is a slicing device.
It is a plane with
a blade in it that
allows you to slice very,
very thin without taking
any of your knuckles or
fingers with whatever you're
slicing very, very thin.
I like to use those for
making home potato chips
and things like that.
JAMES SYHABOUT: So I like
to use-- at Commis, we
cook very light,
very minimal butter,
not so much scorching
heat, because we
want to still remain intact
the entirety of the vegetable.
So everything sits
really gently sweated.
So this is just grapeseed oil.
Grapeseed is the most neutral
oil that you can probably get.
It doesn't impart any flavor.
But it's a fat.
It will help you.
Just slices of kohlrabi.
LARS RYSSDAL: And grapeseed oil
burns at a higher temperature,
lower temperature than
olive oil or canola oil?
JAMES SYHABOUT: It smokes
at a higher temperature.
So ideally, I use grapeseed
oil for flavoring, making
flavored oils.
Like we're going to make
our dill oil with grapeseed.
AUDIENCE: Where do you
buy that [INAUDIBLE]?
JAMES SYHABOUT:
The grapeseed oil?
AUDIENCE: No, the vegetable.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Kohlrabi?
Whole Foods.
Farmers markets might
have it right now.
LARS RYSSDAL: It's
fairly widely available.
It's a very stable vegetable.
It stays in its ripe state
for a very long time.
So it's easy for people
to stock them in stores.
So it's really
versatile and again will
be in the produce--
it will stay fresh
in the produce section
for a long time.
You start to smell
it a little bit?
It's good.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
With seasoning, I
like to season
throughout my cooking.
Some people like to
season at the end only.
Only because I like to
create some depth with salt.
Also salt allows
you to draw moisture
from the ingredient, from
whatever vegetable you have.
It sort of really highlights--
just a little small pinch.
Just be careful not to color.
LARS RYSSDAL: So James,
you guys-- you really
encourage an atmosphere
of collaboration at Commis
in particular.
The menu is constantly
changing, where at Hawker Fare,
they're foods from your youth.
And the menu is
relatively consistent
as you would go there
from one month to the next
to another year.
But in Commis, it's-- you spoke
of this being a spring dish.
The menu is evolving daily.
And that involves--
and you've got
a lot of collaboration going.
People here are collaborating
on projects all the time.
How do you accept things,
and how do you politely
decline an idea?
JAMES SYHABOUT: At
Commis, we believe--
we don't cook on
a timeline per se.
People say, oh, how often
do you change the menu?
I'm like, I couldn't tell you.
It depends what
shows up tomorrow.
It depends what shows up two
days later, what we have,
or what one of my cooks
found hiking in the woods.
Or Morgan went out
surfing in Santa Cruz
and found some beach herbs.
So it kind of all depends.
We look at the menu as a
breathing-- its own thing,
and it's living and breathing.
So we print menus every day.
The menu's always a
surprise to the guests.
We never present menus.
We just ask for
dietary restrictions,
and then off we go.
But collaboration
is a big part only
because I like to give my
cooks a sense of ownership.
I think it's very important
when you're creating something.
Yes, I'm the mentor.
Yes, it's my restaurant.
But I want to give them
a sense of ownership.
So a lot of the dishes, they
need to have a voice in it.
I'll have this crazy idea.
I'll say, Keoni, oxtails
and blueberry powder.
Make it happen.
And he's just like, oh, OK.
How about a little thyme
cream and burnt milk?
And I was like,
yeah, sounds great.
And we don't know till we do it.
So yeah.
That's a good part.
And then when the dish
becomes fully realized,
he feels like he has
ownership or there's
a piece of him in there.
And he's like really
proud of that dish.
At Commis, we have
an open kitchen.
So a lot of the food
gets brought to the table
by the cooks as well.
So it's kind of
taking another step
and bridging that-- eliminating
that bridge between the diner
and the kitchen as well.
I think that's very,
very unique and cool.
Back to the soup.
I added a little bit of water.
Sometimes I use vegetable
stock if they have it
on hand, just a
little gentle simmer.
I'm going to let that go.
AUDIENCE: When do
you use the greens?
JAMES SYHABOUT: The greens.
I use the greens at the
last minute in my soup.
It gives a color.
And also-- so this is going
to be cooking to a mush.
So it's overdone.
The greens, the leafy
greens, the more vegetal,
I throw in at the end
right before I blend it.
And it kind of gives it
that raw vegetable taste
that I can't get if I just
blended raw vegetables.
So it's kind of like
cheating in a way.
LARS RYSSDAL: And
it picks up color
to create this
beautiful contrast
in the dish from this brilliant
red fish and some green
in the soup that is
hosting the fish.
So it's a striking
contrast in color.
JAMES SYHABOUT: And because
I'm blending it raw,
I'm even chopping
this even finer
because I don't want to cook it.
I'm just going to throw it
in, throw it in my blender,
throw my soup in,
puree it, and pass it.
LARS RYSSDAL: So be careful.
It sound like there'll
be a lot of throwing
going on here in a few minutes.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Not literally.
So while that's going,
I'll set this aside.
LARS RYSSDAL: So gosh, you're
opening a new restaurant
tonight in San Francisco.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yeah.
LARS RYSSDAL: Did you
sweat before you came here?
And now you're-- or are you--
JAMES SYHABOUT: I've been
sweating five years ago
when I opened Commis.
AUDIENCE: How long
did it take you
to plan opening up
that new restaurant?
JAMES SYHABOUT: You know,
the hunk of it at SF
was never, ever conceived.
I was actually in
Thailand in September
when someone approached
me with an idea.
I was like, yeah,
sure, whatever.
You're dreaming.
Whatever.
So I got back in
October, and we sat down.
And it was just like,
put some ink on paper.
And I'm like, OK, off we go.
And three months
later, we're opening
a restaurant in the Mission.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yeah, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Where is it?
JAMES SYHABOUT:
Valencia and 18th,
right next door to Luna Park.
I don't know much
about San Francisco.
But everyone tells you it's
like the eye of the storm
right now, as far as
demographics and things like
that.
I grew up in
Oakland all my life.
So it's--
LARS RYSSDAL: So
you've only been
coming across the
bridge heading west
in the last couple
of months then.
You've never gone across
the bridge before?
JAMES SYHABOUT:
Exactly, exactly.
The first couple months,
I was getting frustrated
because I'm so spoiled having
ample parking in Oakland
and not getting tickets.
And it was just like, oh,
this is no fun at all.
But I got used to
it really fast.
I had to.
I didn't have a choice.
So we want to cure our
salmon in the meantime.
With curing salmon, we're
pretty much making gravlax.
The way I cure salmon
is I still like
to have it taste somewhat
itself, almost raw.
I don't want to take it too
far where it's like gravlax,
and all you taste is salt
and sugar and spices.
So I usually do, depending on
the thickness of the salmon,
just like a one-hour cure.
I usually do two parts
salt to one part sugar.
Sugar helps retain moisture.
Salt draws moisture.
So it kind of gives a pull.
If it's just all salt,
it'd be all salty.
And it would be dry.
I'm just going to
eyeball it here.
Feel free to be creative.
That's the whole thing.
Sometimes I would put
lemon zest in here,
black pepper, coriander.
And in curing salmon,
I've seen techniques
where you pack it
with salt heavily.
I just like a light sprinkle.
As you're just heavily
seasoning something,
you don't have to dump it on.
Usually I do it
with skin on salmon
only because it's much
more easy to slice.
But we're just going
to work with this.
And just let that sit in the
refrigerator for an hour or so.
LARS RYSSDAL: Covered,
wrapped up tightly
in wax paper, plastic.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Exactly.
LARS RYSSDAL: Any weight on it?
Some people put weight--
JAMES SYHABOUT: No, just as is.
LARS RYSSDAL: --on fish to
help the curing process.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yeah, we
kind of want the salmon
to be kind of unadulterated
in this state.
LARS RYSSDAL: OK.
And you're using king salmon
or Chinook salmon in this case?
JAMES SYHABOUT: We
usually use wild steelhead
when it's in season,
coming from Oregon or so.
We try not to use farmed
salmon, only because the flavor
is-- to me, it's
nothing special.
You can get it year round.
But when salmon season-- like
local king salmon, we use.
We use ivory salmon, which is
more ivory flesh from Alaska
that's really fantastic
and high in fat.
But no, king salmon's just
as good, like farmed salmon.
It's just fattier only
because it doesn't run wild.
But I think the
most flavor comes
from like river,
sockeye wild salmon.
I'll put this aside there.
LARS RYSSDAL: And in
preparing the fish,
are you taking bones out along
the spine line of the fish?
Are you--
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yes.
I usually take the
pin bone of the fish.
Or your fish market
will do it for you.
But you can do it yourself.
It depends.
Like me-- we get salmon
that are 20 pounds.
So it's a big piece.
So the kohlrabi is
somewhat tender.
Like I said, I might
add the leaves just so.
I'm just bringing it back
to a boil just to scald.
AUDIENCE: I can't really see.
Is there still water left,
or did it all boil out?
JAMES SYHABOUT: You can
adjust with more water
because the trick
is you want to get
the soup as thick as you can.
And you can always adjust.
It's harder to take it away.
LARS RYSSDAL: So
the question was
about how much liquid
is still in the pan.
And there is still
a ratio of, I'd say,
a third liquid to two
thirds of the kohlrabi.
That liquid will need to be
in there to help emulsify
in the blender to
help create that soup.
So it's not gone dry.
It's not steamed dry.
There's still liquid in
there, and you'll see it.
JAMES SYHABOUT: There's a
trick with blending soups.
I like to leave the blender
on for like five minutes,
like a long, very long time.
LARS RYSSDAL: And
would you say, when
you're furnishing your
home, is the first thing you
get a couch or a
Vitamix Vita-Prep 3?
JAMES SYHABOUT: That's
a good question.
That's a good question.
You see how green it is?
You wouldn't get that if
you were to cook everything.
Again, I'm adjusting
this recipe to kohlrabi.
Kohlrabi, cabbage, things
like sauerkraut and things
like that.
I like to add a little bit,
just a touch of sour cream
to kind of give it
some smoothness.
It can also act as an
emulsifier as well.
LARS RYSSDAL: Now if
Julia Child was here,
that would have been
a pound of butter.
He's used about a
tablespoon of sour cream.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
What does she say?
Moderation, but a
whole lot of it.
Yeah.
That was always a good one.
I'll sort of just let it go.
I won't go for five minutes.
AUDIENCE: How long did
you boil the leaves for?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Just throw
it in, bring it up, scald it,
and then that's it.
LARS RYSSDAL: Just a kind
of a real hard blanch almost
to soften a little
bit, fix color, not let
the color fade in
too much cooking,
and keep the green element
in flavor and in color
to the dish.
And it's just beautiful.
It looks like it's
plugged in right now.
It's battery powered soup.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
And then you would
want to chill it
immediately because you
don't want to
overcook the leaves.
It turns that army greenish
color and loses its freshness.
LARS RYSSDAL: Pardon me.
I'm going to take this
out of the way here.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
Sorry about that.
LARS RYSSDAL: So they can
see your hands and face.
JAMES SYHABOUT: So
we've got our soup,
and then we're going
to make dill oil.
Herb oils in general,
grapeseed oil,
I usually do equal
parts by weight.
We cook in metric
at the restaurants
only because it's more accurate.
A cup of sugar or
a cup of flour,
it depends how much
you fill that cup.
Or it could be how dry it is.
But with weight, it doesn't lie.
So with dill oil,
just lightly chop.
Can we have somebody
grab me another chinois?
I eat stems and all.
It's fine.
We'll save some for garnish.
And dill oil is one
of those things where
it can be in your
pantry staple, like herb
oils, chili oils, basil oil.
We usually have a library
of different oils.
It's another way we
preserve seasons, actually.
Like bay leaf flowers
from bay leaves.
It comes maybe two
weeks in a year.
The whole team,
like six of us, will
go out to the Oakland Hills,
grab bags of bay leaf flowers,
pick them all, make oil
with it, dehydrate it.
And we have it for
the rest of the year.
Just kind of taking advantage
of our landscape, per se.
Let's see.
She's got a chinois for me?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
We'll grab one.
JAMES SYHABOUT: OK.
So it's pretty simple.
Blanching locks in
the color of the dill
and also denatures the
filaments a little.
It makes it more tender.
So it gives it a
smoother puree as well.
And I'm going to taste this.
LARS RYSSDAL: Always taste.
And clean spoons.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
So this would be--
it's a cold dish
because you don't
want the salmon to be cooked.
And then can somebody
grab me the thing
of dill oil already made
up there at the top?
The green bowl.
So this is dill
oil that we made.
We blanched the dill,
wring out all of the water
as much as we can, which is
really important because you
don't want-- oil
and water don't mix.
And water will actually
help oxidize the dill oil.
And we let it sit,
and what happens--
we decanter it and pass
it through a cheesecloth.
So it gets this vibrant green.
You can pass that around.
I have extra oil.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
It's not infused.
It's not dill-infused oil.
It's--
JAMES SYHABOUT: It's
pretty much infused.
Yeah.
Because we're getting
all the essential oils.
LARS RYSSDAL: So the
question was, would this
be-- the terminology
would be infused oil?
And yes, it would be
considered infused oil.
But the other thing is if you're
making oils at home like this,
how long would you
recommend keeping those?
JAMES SYHABOUT: If you
keep it in refrigeration
with no light, three months.
LARS RYSSDAL: So you could
set up a large bottle of oil
and a set of infusions,
and keep them cool and dark
for a long period of time.
And use a drop or two on
top of whatever it was you
were doing that would be
germane to that flavor
and enhance that flavor.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yeah.
It also freezes really well,
because oil doesn't freeze.
But it keeps it from oxidizing.
LARS RYSSDAL: So if you were
making then bloody marys,
and you wanted dill oil
ice cubes or oil ice cubes,
you could do that
too, that would
be fun on, well, every day.
But yeah, no, every day.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Could
I grab one of the-- can
I have one of those
bowls for plating?
Thank you.
LARS RYSSDAL: And of
course, the full recipe
that James had submitted
to us is in the book.
So although he eyeballed
the salt and sugar,
the measurements
are in the recipe
in the book for this dish.
JAMES SYHABOUT: It's so funny.
When I started cooking
Thai food again,
which I never thought
in my wildest dreams--
I kind of disowned my
heritage, just growing up.
But it was just like I
was doing it all wrong.
It's like a total
opposite discipline.
Watching my mom
cook with her hands,
just measuring, oh, a
handful of sugar, a handful
of this, a handful of that.
But it actually
shows, like instinct.
The reason why we measure things
is because in fine dining,
it's more of a science, per se.
And it's all about
ratios and whatnot.
But with Thai cooking,
it's very instinctual.
You don't want
ingredients to taste
like it's all bottled sauces.
It's like a little mixology.
It's like a little bit of
this, a little bit of that.
Everyone makes their
sauces totally different.
That's where I kind
of-- where I'm at.
I'm coming to learn.
Sometimes you kind of get
too geeked out on food.
And it takes-- I think the
soul gets removed from it.
And there's nothing wrong with
having instinct and owning it.
Anyone can read-- anyone can
follow a recipe with a scale.
But I think it's all about
making that dish your own.
So don't ever be afraid to
throw in your own ideas,
leave some things out
that you don't like, add
something in that you do like.
Trust me.
We have many failures at Commis.
There's some dishes, I'm
like, ew, it's gross.
It's great ideas on paper.
LARS RYSSDAL: Yeah.
It's just a churn.
When we make ice cream at
home, and it doesn't work,
it goes away.
And we say, it's just a churn.
If you don't like what you've
cooked, it's just a dish.
Start over and learn from it.
JAMES SYHABOUT: One of my pastry
chefs-- for New Year's Eve
at Commis, I let all my-- I
don't write the menu at all.
I'm totally hands off.
And all my chefs write the menus
and their names on the dish.
And one of the dishes
was-- the pastry chef
wanted to do coffee and
cigarettes for New Year's
Eve at the end of the meal.
So I think it was like chocolate
ganache and tobacco ice cream.
It was disgusting.
It was gross.
LARS RYSSDAL: Hopefully
it was after midnight,
and no one cared.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
But we figured out
the way-- it was
too much nicotine.
He used cigarettes
instead of cigars.
So we found a nice Cuban cigar.
The dish actually
went on the menu.
It just needed some finessing.
I blanched out the
nicotine a couple of times.
So like I said, it's
collaboration work.
It starts with the idea.
And then we keep working
on the idea to-- nothing
gets lost or gets thrown out.
It kind of gets filed for
revisiting until it's-- until
we can't figure out anymore.
It's like, all right.
LARS RYSSDAL: So buddy,
in the interest of time,
we'll have some questions.
And let's-- if we
can dish this up.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
Yes, let's do it.
LARS RYSSDAL: And take
questions and get you guys fed.
Yay.
And learn more about
what's on your mind
after this discussion.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Did
that taste all good?
I didn't taste it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm wondering how the
San Francisco Hawker
Fare is going to be different
from the Oakland Hawker Fare?
JAMES SYHABOUT: We have
a much larger kitchen.
We went under kind
of more rebranding.
And there's a lot more
curries and soups, a lot more
chili dips.
The ambiance is
totally different.
So it's kind of
Hawker Fare grew up.
The original Hawker
Fare had graffiti,
and I got rid of that.
So it looks like more
of a night market now.
AUDIENCE: So it's
a different menu?
JAMES SYHABOUT: Hmm?
AUDIENCE: It's a
slightly different menu?
JAMES SYHABOUT:
It's the same menu
plus a bunch of other
different items.
My chef de cuisine there
is originally from Bangkok.
So he comes from a
different point of reference
as far as Thai food.
I'm from the east, from
Ubon, close to Laos.
So it's a much drier climate.
Everything's more funky.
Everything's spicier.
So me and him always butt heads.
So that's why the Hawker
Fare in San Francisco,
we have a Thai style
som tam, and we also
have a Lao style som tam.
One's more sweet with
peanuts and dried shrimp.
The other one's sour
and funky with shards
of salted crab in it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it sounds
like you're really
spread thinly with
so many places
you're working on right now.
How do you-- what's
your role in each place?
That's the first
part of the question.
Do you just oversee?
Do you come and try?
And then where is home for you?
Which place do you go to
and actually cook and enjoy
and create?
LARS RYSSDAL: That's a
really good question.
JAMES SYHABOUT: It
depends on my mood.
It depends where
I'm out of touch.
But my role overall is I'm kind
of hoping, holding hands, kind
of guiding them through
all the concepts and kind
of pushing them to do
research for new dishes.
I took my chef from
Hawker Fare, Oakland
to Thailand for a month, and
that's all we did was eat out.
So I'm more of a
facilitator for them.
I kind of come up
with the ideas,
help put systems in place.
And I just hold their hands.
And for me, where's home for me?
It depends on my mood.
Some days, I just want to
wear jeans and sneakers
and a t-shirt, and go mortar
and pestle some papaya salad.
And some days, I
want to put tweezers
out and put on a
starched chef's coat
and get geeked out on using
a scale and liquid nitrogen.
So I go through modes.
I think I'm very fortunate
I have those outlets, which
is very helpful because
when I'm at one restaurant,
I'm actually looking
at the other restaurant
from the outside point of view.
Sometimes I'm at
Commis, I'm working
on dishes for Hawker Fare, and
I will serve it as a staff meal,
get feedback from them.
But yeah.
I mean, I would love to
be at Commis every day.
It's kind of my sanctuary.
You have to use all white.
There's not art.
I can think clear.
Everything's very calm.
Everything's very-- there's no
surprises, per se, at Commis.
At Hawker Fare, there's
always an element of surprise.
It gets fast-paced.
It gets bustling.
But sometimes,
you need that too.
Just get the--
awake your senses.
Get the pulse going.
So I'm very, very
fortunate I have
those two different
outlets to run to.
LARS RYSSDAL: OK.
And a question here?
AUDIENCE: Hi, Seth.
So I live right around the
corner from Box and Bells.
Unfortunately, it's closed.
I was curious, what
do you think didn't
work about that restaurant?
I thought it was wonderful.
But obviously, it
didn't seem to connect.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
Sometimes, as a chef,
you're really passionate
about something.
And you kind of want to
just stick to your guns.
And I really wanted
a place where
it was a very meat-centric
place, hopeful.
Our opening menu was awesome,
but it was not for everyone.
There was blood pudding poutine
on there and rib eye for two
with snails, choucroute garnie.
We made our own sausages.
I was awesome.
It was either people
who love it or hated it.
It depends on the neighborhood
and the financial model too.
With being Rockridge,
you need to be
more in the middle,
what I've found.
And that's something I
couldn't get myself to do.
And I just-- I want to stand
behind the food I cook.
And I think, same
for the cooks too.
I'm like, well, are we
excited about doing this,
or-- yes, we're in hospitality.
We want to click.
But when we're slaving behind
the stove for 16 hour days,
let's make ourselves happy here.
Come on.
Let's not lie to ourselves.
So unfortunate, but time
and place for everything.
AUDIENCE: Do you have a
favorite restaurant in Oakland
that's not yours?
JAMES SYHABOUT: I like
to go to order pizza,
like Charlie Hallowell's
places, like Boot and Shoe
Service and Pizzaiolo.
I love going to those places.
My kids-- I have
a three-year-old
and an 18-month-old.
So it's like our staple, go-to.
It's just fantastic.
It's easygoing.
It's just delicious
home-cooked meals.
It's very representative
of a home cooked feel it
in that genre of Chez
Panisse and whatnot.
LARS RYSSDAL: Let's
finish the dish.
And then we can--
Victoria can get
the books for people
for you to sign.
JAMES SYHABOUT: One thing.
After it's cured,
you can rinse it.
Cold water.
LARS RYSSDAL: So the
sugar and the salt
have been sort of cooking
the fish a little bit.
And now to let the-- as James
was talking about earlier,
he wanted the flavor of
the fish to rule this, not
the flavor of salt and sugar.
JAMES SYHABOUT:
What we do at Commis
is we remove the
fat from the salmon
only because it
makes it too fishy.
LARS RYSSDAL: So that's
the skin side of the--
JAMES SYHABOUT: The
skin side, yeah.
LARS RYSSDAL: The skin side of
the fish that you're trimming,
the part that was
next to the skin.
Clean the fish up a little bit.
JAMES SYHABOUT: And
the loin is actually
going to be a lot leaner
than the belly piece.
So kind of pick and
choose what you like.
Just small bite sized pieces.
I'm going to do two pieces.
LARS RYSSDAL: About
one inch cubes,
something like
that, it looks like.
JAMES SYHABOUT: So I usually
put a little bit of a finishing,
like a coarse sea salt.
A little bit of dill oil.
And then usually-- we
have micro greens today,
but usually it's
all kinds of herbs.
Herbs right now that
we find in the hills--
it could be chickweed, grown
elder, yarrow, New Zealand
spinach, tetragon.
So it could be sometimes
up to 30 different herbs
that we just picked.
And sometimes we buy
too from a farmer
in Sebastopol for anise
hyssop and things like that.
But these are kind of
like-- I like licorice,
so I always tend to go for more
licorice flavor herbs, which
wasn't the case
when I was younger,
because you kind of grow up.
You can put some dill
in there as well.
I always serve it
in a nice cold bowl.
It's very refreshing.
And I would even pair this with
like a dry Riesling at work.
LARS RYSSDAL: Dry
Riesling with that?
Fantastic.
JAMES SYHABOUT: Yeah.
So it's kind of like
really, really simple.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So one
more time-- thanks,
everyone, for coming today.
LARS RYSSDAL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]